let's have a look at the one pull the
immature speeds many now this no normos
is like less it's a less common word
it's the same it's the same very hard to
say like taxonomy or anything like kana
me or there's lobby words right
nothing words yeah not accept notable
exception is all about anyway does they
don't know what abate and that name is
really a pleaser
one other words we get from there in
this context what it really means is
terms or elements or phrases
okay so it just means many terms now
what does that relate to well back in
the array even though you might not have
actually had it told you this was but
under like quadratics and that could be
we talk about factorize you if you
looked at the program you would have
seen this my Springer I try
we talked about factorizing trinomial
expressions by which we mean stuff like
x squared plus 5x plus 6 you can see
there are three terms right and in year
12 actually I'm gonna cover it in a few
weeks in my in my new top class we've
got this whole topic called binomial
expansions
which is all to do with taking things
like say I don't like X minus three and
then raising them to crazy kinds of
powers like say 40 or 50 or 400 okay so
that thing in there that's the binomial
there are two terms and then you expand
it out and there's this whole is all
fear to do with this okay that's the new
Pascal's triangle anyway so therefore
that's all that's all polynomials that's
that's all motor needs okay but that
kind of disguises why we study
pollinators I might have really cool
polynomials and particularly the
solutions to polynomial equations are
actually a really important family of
numbers that you've probably never heard
of but you actually you actually work
with all the time this set of numbers is
called I'm gonna give you you know how
we talked about of introduce and that
kind of thing like when we were doing
general solution and we say you know a
number like n belongs to the set of
integers right so there was that funky
looking Zed which is just our way of
saying whole numbers okay so here this
set of numbers has its own set notation
it's a funky looking aid what it stands
for is does anyone know
no I take too long sorry just because
the name is too much it's a set of
algebraic numbers yeah has anyone ever
heard that that phrase before
yeah probably yeah yeah maybe I wouldn't
be surprised if you've never heard of it
before because it's kind of like an
umbrella term I'll explain it in a
second all right we'll come back to it
now let's just really quickly Radloff
some examples of polynomials and then
we'll try and generalize out instead
what's the general point okay so X minus
1 X 2 actually had some actually I put
let's make this
x squared minus five
it's very possible
okay so these are all polynomials right
what are some things to know you've got
these X terms here and you've got
different powers sometimes coming up
you've also got these numbers out the
front you actually all the numbers
really they're all integers that's
important okay if I chuck like a square
root personal or something like that
into here okay it would cease to be a
polynomial all of these powers as well
they all must be positive when they're
when you take negative powers even if it
ceases to be a permanent now while I
pick out these ones well you remember I
said that the solutions to polynomial
equations are this set of numbers okay
so here are some polynomial expressions
let's turn them into polynomial
equations okay so just an equal sign on
that now I picked these particular
equations for a reason because what are
the solutions to these specific
equations well socially this one is one
okay and that's that's it that's a whole
number right the solution to this one is
minus 1 and 1/2 minus 3 onto you okay
which is number one it's negative right
so it's not just positive numbers you
can gather this but also it's not an
integer at all it's rational right it's
a ratio it's a fraction yeah okay how
about this one
okay so you're gonna get not just one
but two solutions is and also they're
sir solutions right eight irrational
okay so it's not just these kinds of you
know happy sometimes you get cubed
solutions okay now there are no real
solutions because these solutions up
here these are these are the real real
numbers okay but this is not a real
number it's another kind of know that
you know about namely it's a it's an
imaginary solution watching two
imaginary solutions which is a terrible
name because there's nothing like you
know imaginary about them it's just you
can't measure these kinds of numbers
okay so you're bringing it by which is
the square root of negative one okay
because there are no lengths or
magnitudes that can go into this
individually all right now let's have a
look at this one now without actually
solving it you already see there's a
package e in that each one of these
equations gives you a different kind of
family and not lose what's the
difference here what's there between
this one this one yeah
the actual solution to this one is plus
or minus the square root of minus 5 okay
which we can write as plus or minus
square root of 5 fine okay so the
important things to note is that all of
this has to do with this it's all
attached to the I it's all imaginary ok
but if you go ahead and solve this you
can use the formula or complete the
square what if you like and what you get
is not just an imaginary part but there
will also be a real part right so when
you have both of those together we call
that a complex number right a complex
number is that there's a combination of
those two okay now here's the kicker
right all of these numbers right even
though they are so diverse and very very
like you know where where do these kinds
of numbers come from this comes from
counting this comes from sharing this
comes from geometry and my Pythagoras
that kind of thing this comes from it's
hard to explain electricity physics oh
this comes from more electricity and
more physics okay but
not like I said the solution he will be
I don't actually know what the numbers
are but it's like 3 plus or minus you
know square root of 3i or something like
that so there's this two parts 20
Michael yeah
not the ones that were interested I'm
sorry I see what you mean yeah um didn't
I say that I thought the powers are all
the numbers here that I've listed it are
integers when we're talking about what
needs to be an integer because as you
can see if I took for instance let's go
root 3 X plus 1 equals 0 what will the
solution of that me 3 so it still
belongs in this set you're still getting
an outright number at the end which is
why ok it's ok so this is uh this whole
set is the set of algebraic numbers now
here's my question to you what kinds of
numbers don't fit into this set because
that's a lot infinity doesn't fit in
there because infinity is not a number
concept a very useful concept but still
not one that you can actually sub in to
something yeah X X is also number its
variable looking for constancy the
family of numbers that doesn't belong
here that some the compliment if you
might remember complements so if you got
shared right if you're sticking or wavy
line at the top that means not zr2 not a
whole number the the compliment to the
algebraic numbers here is a set that
you've heard on before it's a more
famous set they called the
transcendental numbers
I am somewhat disappointed if you've
never heard that name at least because
the numbers that fit into this set are
very famous you've been working with
them since you seven at least nothing's
like say PI right numbers like say E or
the log of any algebraic no law actually
okay so except me these numbers here
right where did they come from
well this number comes from mainly
circles but it comes up in weird other
random places this comes from natural
growth which we'll look at a bit more we
do expenditure growth in the K this is
the same thing these are just two your
size the same point but importantly
right these numbers they don't come from
the way that we build numbers this is
the way humans build numbers we and we
subtract we multiply we multiply again
anything again that's what
exponentiation is about okay but these
numbers come from from somewhere else
okay this 3.1415 this ratio there's
2.718 to do bubble of allah we can't you
there's no equality equation you can
build to which these are the solutions
okay so because they're they are beyond
the ways that we build numbers we say if
they transcend transcendental numbers
okay now by the way just there's a weird
wonderful coffee which has nothing to do
with this topic okay you take the two
most famous transcendental numbers right
and if you put them together in an
unusual way they raise it to the power
pi and just stick another imaginary
number than them the square root of
negative one okay
transcendental another transcendental
this guy is just a weird odd ball it
doesn't fit with other people does
anyone know what this is equal to almost
now just just think about that for a
second okay weird numbers antisocial
number right and you come out fee of
it's not quite I mean
posit counting numbers you look good
might be calculator
it's about as sweet as you can get you
throw them together and out comes this I
find that really unsettling okay now I
could explain the geometry of this if
you if you're curious you can go look up
Euler's identity that's that's the name
of this equation but it's this these are
the kinds of numbers and expressions
that we going to do it